[Music]
it's like we called each other we
totally you wear your suit dress yeah I
was like how are you both doing good I
mean I didn't get the memo on the all
black I know but here's the thing
usually I don't usually on the Christmas
shows I wear a lot red and I thought I
can't wear red again I've worn it so
much I just love the color thank you
thank you so to y'all I love that you're
doing something together this is
exciting for all the
F yeah so breaking news you're engaged
don't you worry my
you're engaged I am that's exciting oh
my goodness are you so happy oh my
goodness
oh oh look at
your a I love it I'm cry look at this
the best gift like right before
Christmas Yes it truly is yeah oh we
have tissue I
swear oh I love you K I was like I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry I didn't mean to make
you cry I was like it's a beautiful
thing no it is thank you very much but
um your makeup artist is like call the
tears yes um we just got engaged
yesterday oh my
God what a big your life is about to
just 180 they Co in it is it is it's
it's wonderful been together eight years
oh wow yes be well you know you love
each other at this point oh yes William
by now yeah angel I call him my angel a
that's a good song um it's older than
y'all but whatever my generation
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home